Hello Freak bitches for,
but even if we did,
it's worth repeating.
I talked about an article,
an article that was done by some colleagues of mine,
I don't know them well,
but some,
some academics where they looked at the,
uh,
political affiliation of professors at top,
I think it was California in schools,
whether they identified it or whether they actually had democratic affiliation
or Republican.
And as you might imagine,
it was extraordinarily skewed towards Democrats,
but then depending on the field of study,
so for example,
in sociology and in the humanities and in women's studies,
women with a y,
by the way,
please don't write women with an e.
That would be sexist at even,
as I said,
the women's oftentimes and women's studies,
they,
they think that to have men as part of the word women is itself a form of
aggression.
So they've altered the spelling to with men.
Oh no,
that's not real.
So you see,
I know your audience already has the price of admission covered with that story,
but it's still the word women,
right?
So anyway,
so the same word,
why do you have to change the letters?
So in sociology,
do you train,
change the word trigger because it sounds like the n word or a right,
you're getting triggered.
I'm triggered,
I'm triggered.
Well,
I'm fucking triggered.
If I was black,
I'd be super triggered,
but I don't know if you notice some of my tweets now,
whenever I tweet anything,
I put a trigger warning trigger warning.
It's not become part of the vernacular to make it sit there vertical.
It's too close to the n word.
Way Too close.
I am triggered.
But anyways,
to to finish the point about that study 44 to one,
the ratio in sociology.
So imagine if you are a student doing an Undergrad in sociology,
right?
It's not a very good thing to have.
Almost all of the professors that you will ever come across be of one particular
persuasion.
Now,
some people would write to me and say,
but what do you mean?
The Democrats have everything,
right?
They have truth on their side and the Republicans are a bunch of hacks.
Now when it comes to evolution evolution,
that's true,
right?
If,
if,
if on average republicans are more likely to deny evolution than that point is
well taken,
but when it comes to issues,
is the death penalty,
right or wrong?
What's kind of fiscal policy should you have?
What type of foreign policy should you have?
This is not a one plus one scientific equation,
so you should be exposed to multiple viewpoints,
but of course you shouldn't be because you should only interact with people who
are similar to you will that,
that is a problem with a lot of people that go to college,
graduate,
get their phd,
get their doctorate,
and then start teaching and never enter the real world,
right?
They stay in this sort of insulated world of academia and then they espouse
these same ideas.
They promote these same idea.
They promote the same way of thinking as if this is the real world because this
is the only world they know.
True.
So my friend,
uh,
luther reigns,
he ended up,
he had a massive stroke and now he's actually for somehow.
So when,
when you have withdrawals from painkillers,
it feels like you're going to die.
And so when he had the stroke,
they said,
get his mother here,
he's not gonna make it through this.
And we can pump them full on full of enough drugs for him to get through this.
He's gonna.
He's probably not going to make it.
Somehow miraculously the part of the,
uh,
the brain that is like 30 percent of his brain got killed during the stroke.
Part of the brain that got killed was the part that was responsible for feeling
withdrawals.
So somehow he fucking dodged a bullet.
We called the bulletproof bad boy.
I'm somehow he bullet,
he's alive.
He has no more hangovers.
He's completely sober and he goes around and talks to kids and churches and
things like that.
So he's doing great work.
So he lost 30 percent of his brain.
Yeah.
But somehow he's still a cognitive.
He's still,
you know,
he's still there.
He's jacked.
I mean,
still.
So he's on steroids.
Yeah,
she's fucking Christ.
Might be to be on something.
Yeah.
So he's off the pain pills on steroids and helping out kids.
There you go.
What the fuck out of a world we live in.
I love that one day we were eating with them,
uh,
that we're grabbing a burger or something and he's,
he's got this fanny pack on.
He's like pulling stuff out.
He's trying to find his money,
you know,
he's like,
oh,
I'll pay for it bro.
And he's like moving in slow motion.
He's fucking drooling.
I'm like,
this guy's amazing.
What is going on with this guy?
He's putting all these like different bottles of pills,
like on the table,
he's got like Viagra and a bunch of other shit and carries a bottle with him.
Yeah.
And then he put like his fanny pack.
Well there's Bob tools,
the many bottles and then he puts down like a little bag,
like a clear bag of something and he's like,
he looks at it and he grabs money clip and he puts his money on the table and it
looks at the clear baggies like,
whoops.
And he puts that back,
whatever the fuck that was.
That was like,
that wasn't okay for him to put on the table.
Everything else was fine for some reason.
He's like,
oops,
big old stack of cash.
That's so crazy.
Oh my God,
I was like,
dude,
what if you get your pills mixed up like you're just running a ton of fucking
Viagra and shit like that,
but we have to be weird that when,
when people are taking these powerful mind altering substances which can have
these wonderful things as you and I have experienced,
we got to be aware that there are people who are not as stable as they think
they are.
People who have deep seeded shit going on and they don't know what's buried
that's going to come flying out people or don't understand that yet.
If you're going to jump jump from the first floor,
not the fifth floor,
so we got to make sure because the jump from the first floor,
the ground floor,
the ground.
Exactly.
You know,
but that it's going to be so key because I mean,
look,
just to shift away from the sales for a second,
one of the issues we're working on big time is trying to reduce the number of
people dying from overdoses involving either heroin or pharmaceutical opiates.
For the last couple of years,
more people have died of an accidental overdose involving heroin or other
pharmaceuticals.
They had a car accident is the number one cause of accidental death in America
today.
I mean,
it's absolutely crazy stuff.
Right?
And in fact,
when we say overdoses suggests you took too much.
Most of what our overdose is actually or drug combinations.
They're typically doing this.
Opiate,
pharmaceutical,
opiate,
oxy Kodo,
and whatever it might be might be prescribed to you with booze or with Benzos,
valium type trucks.
Right?
So what we're trying to do is to put out there the notion that don't care if you
do it.
Opiates,
don't combine it with booze.
Don't combine it with tranquilizers.
There's a miracle drug called the locks up and we're trying to make that stuff
as widely available.
Reverses the.
It's like an antidote for an overdose.
Make it available.
We're passing nine slash 11 good Samaritan laws.
So if people are around and a buddy there's overdoses,
they don't just flip out.
They call nine slash 11 right away.
The way it was a heart attack.
So you know,
it's true with the psychedelics and marijuana,
but even with the drugs that we see as less elevated in a way with that huge
numbers of people are using life,
the opiates.
It's really important that we become more and more of a society that understands
the notion that we need to make it safer to use these drugs.
Right?
We got to keep people from getting hurt the way that people get hurt.